Fox News had the Patriot Awards in
Florida last week we went for the second
time one of the things that you notice
when you're there is that there's not a
huge difference between the people who
work at Fox and run Fox and the people
who watch Fox and if you've been on TV
for a while that's a rare thing made
that point actually here it is
the cool thing about meeting Fox viewers
is every time I think this oh I I can
relate to that person that person is the
same instincts I do not just the same
ideas but the same gut reaction to
things I like those people
I mean it too
and I can and I will say this
one of my rules is you know like don't
suck up to your employer because that's
kind of craving right
you should always be a little bit
against the man
well I want to thank my employer who
signs my paycheck
but this is real
and I was reminded of tonight because I
was with people who work at Fox and
people who watch Fox and there's not a
big difference actually there really
isn't
they're nice
they're the kind of people who like
actually tip the waiter pretty
generously
and those are the kind of people I love
those kind of people I'm blessed to work
around and live with and those are the
kind of people I'm blessed to have
watched our Channel
so there really is a difference everyone
claims to love other people but some
people love them in the abstract I'm
sending money to a cause I don't
understand in a place I've never been
none of the people who love the people
around them in their immediate orbit
and we have a lot of the second category
here at Fox News and a lot of those
people watch us too and we are grateful
for that anyway we took a bunch of
behind the scenes footage here's some of
it all right so I should keep the
obscenity to minimum when you have a
microphone on officer oh you're the one
I want to talk to how you doing all
right who's best guess that I can have
on and I said Tucker will you come on my
podcast and he's like are you kidding of
course I'm coming on your podcast the
great janistan the bravest person at Fox
is true
you went after the governor of New York
that man Charles cougar my producer just
got two deer
thank you Janice that was wonderful
so we're in the basement delivery area
of a large concrete building and when
you go to see Greg Gutfeld the star of
his magnitude this is where you find
yourself we're entering the gut felt
Zone
oh my God
I gotta be honest Greg and I mean this
from my heart I don't think I've ever
eaten asparagus
I would never eat that I would never eat
that can I bother you three we're
shooting a package for the channel yeah
that's why I asked one question it's
super super easy okay which is what's
your favorite challenge folks
we all say the same thing because
they're different all right three two
one
we don't always tell everybody how we
feel about Tucker but he's always our
secret favorite no he was asking if
Tucker Carlson was here Paris walk who's
a close second
Tucker
worth watching we'll be back 8 P.M
[Applause]
please thank you thank you
come on thanks the sworn enemy of lying
composity smugness and growth thing you
know them Tucker Carlson
so they our producers found people said
they liked the show it's a little
embarrassing I hadn't seen that there
were some great people there though and
again the spread between the people who
work at Fox and run Fox and the people
who watch Fox is basically zero and
that's why people watch Fox because
we're not kidding
you can watch the whole thing by the way
right now if you're interested on Fox
Nation
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight